okay I am I am back and I appreciate
first of all I want to say all of your
concerned emails and and tweets over the
last week and a half I appreciate all
that you know I said when I first signed
back online I got you know check Twitter
and the email and and there are all
these messages from people asking me if
I'm okay if I'm still alive what
happened to me and I am okay I'm alive
although if I wasn't alive I'm not sure
that sending an email would entail to
tell you so I'm not sure logistically it
doesn't make a lot of sense but I was
just on vacation it's all and now I'm
back and that's the whole story well
although I should stipulate I call it a
vacation but I should say that this
quote-unquote vacation involved about
1,500 miles of driving over a week and a
half and which which wouldn't be so bad
in fact it would be enjoyable for me I
like driving if not for the fact that we
have two six-year-olds and two and a
half year old who are also in the car
and I will say that it went about as
well as you could possibly expect when
you lock three young kids in in a
suburban for 35 cumulative hours and you
need drive hither and yon with them it
went about as well as it possibly could
which is just another way of saying that
it was really miserable in fact at the
very last leg of our drive yesterday the
last leg of our last drive we were
almost done and we're about an hour away
from the house in you know it was it was
around dinnertime we knew he wouldn't we
wouldn't have any food at the house
we've been gone so we stopped at Red
Robin for dinner and I must admit that
we were that family in the restaurant
that everybody hates I don't like being
that family I try not to be that family
as much as I possibly can but as parents
we all take our turns being that family
we you know if you haven't been that
family yet you will be one day trust me
and so we were that family yesterday in
the restaurant because our our kids were
bouncing off the walls from being cooped
up in a car my wife and I were exhausted
basically catatonic and so they're
bouncing all over the place and I mean
the bow
we can muster with just please guys
please please please please top that's
the most we could do and it just it
wasn't enough and it gave me flashbacks
to vacationing as when I was a child and
I remember one occasion specifically
well just in general I remember how
tired my parents always were on vacation
I never understood that you know and one
time in particular we were going to
Kings Dominion on vacation and I you
know I have five brothers and sisters to
this day I don't understand why my
parents usually very practical illogical
people why they would think to go on
vacation to an amusement park with six
kids and it still makes me suspect that
they were suffering from some you know a
psychotic episode or something but we
got we got to vacation we got to Kings
Dominion we got around the park we made
it to the hotel and my dad the first
thing you want to do is take a nap he
said I wanted to take a nap and you guys
all just gonna hang out and I was so
traumatized by this I didn't understand
what take a nap a nap we're at an
amusement you want to take a nap what
but now I get it
I really do I totally understand it but
now I'm back anyway
without a nap but but I'm here and
there's a lot to cover because I got to
play catch-up we've got we were talking
with this Ilhan Omar thing we're gonna
talk about Beddoes infanticidal
fantasies a lot of other things but
first before we get to any of that
September is if you weren't aware of
this National Life Insurance Awareness
Month
most people aren't aware of that so we
got to raise awareness of the awareness
month
first of all in fact most people aren't
even aware they need life insurance at
all that's why 40% of Americans don't
have it but getting life insurance
doesn't need to be difficult or
expensive even though you associate it
with with all of that it doesn't need to
be that way right now prices are the
lowest they've been in 20 years and
policy genius has made it easier than
ever to get covered policy genius is the
easy way to shop for life insurance
online in minutes you can compare quotes
from top insurers you can find your best
price that way and once you apply the
policy genius team will handle all the
paperwork all the red tape you don't
have to worry about that and policy
genius doesn't just make life insurance
easy they also help you with home
insurance auto insurance does
the insurance any kind of insurance you
could think of if you need life
insurance but you haven't gotten around
to it yet now this is national life
insurance Awareness Month so this is the
time to do it go to policy genius.com
get quotes and you can apply in minutes
you can do the whole thing on your phone
right now policy genius the easy way to
compare and buy life insurance all right
actually I was um I was going to start
with the Omar thing but I think I'm
gonna start with this instead better
O'Rourke was doing a town hall at the
College of Charleston on Monday and he
got a great question a really great
question I think and delivered a not so
great response so let's watch this this
question answered my question is this I
was born September 8 1989 and I want to
know if you think on September 7th 1981
89 my life had no value
of course I don't think that and of
course I'm glad that you're here but you
you reference my answer in in Ohio and
it remains the same this is a decision
that neither you nor I nor the United
States government should be making
that's a decision for the woman to make
but we want her to have the best
possible access to care and to a medical
provider and I'll tell you the
consequence of this this attack on
woman's right to choose and and and and
I listened to you and I heard your
question I'm answering it and the attack
on on Roe versus Wade which we thought
was the settled law of the land and
unless we had any illusion that the
achievements that we've made are
protected forever or that progress is
inevitable that has been shattered right
now okay now first of all as I said
that's a great question because that's
exactly how it should be framed this is
what I've been preaching for years now
what you know the way that you frame the
question is okay you're saying abortion
is okay up until birth so are you
telling me that my life that your life
was worthless had no value a day before
birth or a second before birth a
nanosecond before birth in fact you know
my wife is 35 weeks pregnant right now
which by the way that also made the
drive really fun because you know at the
stop every 32 minutes for bathroom
breaks and so she started 35 weeks
pretty are you telling me that the
entity in her womb right now the the
being in her womb the the what is a
human life even you don't want to call
it a human life whatever you want to
call it you're telling me it has no
moral worth whatsoev-- none zero mean it
has less moral Worth and then like a
squirrel no claim to life
none at all well Beto says of course I
don't think that no no no but then he
goes on in the next sentence to reveal
that he does in fact think that he says
that's a decision the woman should
and what is the decision this is the
important part that's why I wanted to
talk about this what is the decision the
question was not should my mom had been
allowed to kill me on September 2 on
September 8th 1989 of course the answer
to that from betters perspective is yes
but with that question it is still much
easier to give the answer of at should
be the woman's choice that wasn't the
question the question was did my life
have value on September 8th 1989 and it
was to that question that Beto says well
that's a decision for the woman to make
so what he's saying because look it
would be possible to argue that well the
life has value it is human life I mean
you could are you could argue that it's
it's human life it's even it's a person
with value but it's still okay to kill
it now I would disagree with that
argument that's a bad argument but you
could try to make the argument that way
but that's not what betos doing here
he's saying that it's a decision for the
woman to make what he's saying quite
clearly and explicitly is that the woman
decides the value of a child's life
which is even more extreme that's my
point that to say well yeah all life has
value but sometimes it's okay to kill it
and and which in fact we are with that
general principle we all agree because
it would say you know self-defense is
okay to kill someone in self-defense I
think we all would agree with that but
those of us with a with a with a proper
moral sense those of us who have
well-formed conscience conscience is and
those of us who can think logically
would say that well clearly killing a
baby that was wrong so what I would say
my my principle is it is always wrong to
intentionally kill an innocent and
defenseless human life always wrong in
any certain whether we're talking about
abortion or in any other scenario but
you could you know you could acknowledge
the value of the child's life and then
try to figure out a way to still make
abortion okay
wouldn't it's not gonna be a good
argument you could try to do it but what
would what Beto is doing he's going even
more extreme than that I think this is
an even more extreme position he's
taking where he's saying well the the
the very value of the child's life it's
not just that well she can make a
decision about what to do with this life
that has values she know she gets to
decide whether or not the life he's in
that even has value in the first place
and that of course is what many what
probably most pro-abortion people
believe even if they won't come out and
say it
the woman decides the value so it's not
just the woman decides what to do with
her body now because this is not merely
a question about the woman's body this
is a question about what do we do with
the body of the child and Beto says well
she decides that because she decides
whether the baby's body has any value at
all this raises all kinds of follow-up
questions for you know the first one
being why does she have that power why
why should she have that power why
should she be the one to determine the
actual worth of her child's life and if
she does have that power does she lose
it the moment that she gives birth if so
why again we're not here talking about
her body we're talking about the the
body of the child what worth does that
have no matter where it's located what
worse doesn't have that oh says well she
decides if she does then does does she
still decide even after giving birth to
the child if not if she doesn't then why
and if she doesn't decide the baby's
worth after birth
then who does decide the baby's value
after birth okay the mother decides
before well who decides after if you're
gonna say oh no no all babies that have
been born have of course of incredible
Worth and I says who what where do they
get that worth and value from if now if
you say and this will be my answer I
would say well the baby's value is is
inherent its objective it's just part of
what
they are ok just like nobody decides
that liquid water is wet that's not we
didn't decide that it just is that's a
that's its inherent its part of the
inherent value of the thing it's part of
its nature liquid water is what it's
part of what it means what it means to
be liquid I would say that human life
has value it's what it means to be a
human being but in that case of its
inherent value if the baby has inherent
objective value after birth then he has
to have it before birth also because
that's what those words mean
objective and inherent those are not
objective inherent worth by definition
cannot be gained or added after the fact
you either have it or you don't
ok so there's never a point you know a
triangle always has three sides it's not
like you could have a you have a
triangle pre-existing and then you add
an additional side to give it three
sides well if it didn't have the three
sides before then it wasn't a triangle
before it's part of the inherent nature
of it so you either have it or you don't
if the mother decides the baby's value
before birth then the baby has no
inherent value and then value by
definition in that case is subjective
but if the baby's but if
baby's worth is subjective before birth
then logically it must be subjective
after birth and if a baby has subjective
worth after birth then it stands to
reason that the person or group that
gives him that suggests what subjective
worth is now it's like um it's like a
money okay money has subjective worth
money only is a pick up a hold up a ten
dollar bill that's only worth something
because we decide that it is if we if
all of us tomorrow in the country
decided that ten dollars it doesn't mean
anything to us we don't care about it it
has no value it's not worth anything
anymore
it only has worth because we have all
decided that it has worth
so the worth is really something that
happens in our heads it's not has
nothing to do with that thing
if you're saying that human worth works
that way then that means that the value
of people is just decided by sort of the
general consensus we all just kind of
decide though yeah well we all sort of
like babies you know infants at least
the ones that are born or cute we like
them so they have worth and if that's
the case which is this this is the
logical progression of betos argument if
that's the case then that means we could
rescind that worth we could all decide
you know certain babies don't have worth
which is what we do with unborn babies I
mean and if we could do it there then we
could do it we could say well you know
sick people are kind of a strain on the
economy they don't have a lot of worth
poor people you know disabled people the
elderly you start going down this you
just path of eugenics this is what
eugenics is all about it's all about the
idea that human value is subjective it's
decided by society it's decided by how
useful you are to those around you and
if you're not very useful if people
don't really want you around then we can
just get rid of you because you have no
objective or that's this is this is the
the pro-abortion argument this is where
it leads
and I think Beto I think Beto revealed
that okay before we move on let's check
in with our friends at Proactiv you know
school is finally coming back but
breakouts don't have to parents you know
wouldn't it be great if you could get
your kids clear skin confident for the
new school year because confidence is
where
important when they're going to school
you want the kids to feel good look good
as a parent nothing is worse than seeing
your kids go back to school and knowing
they're not feeling their best they're
having all that there's enough social
anxiety okay trust me when it comes to
school we don't need to add to it and if
there's something causing anxiety that
can be solved then then we should solve
it and that's where America's number-one
Acme brand proactive comes in they have
helped fight acne for almost 25 years
now they're still going strong now with
their next-generation acne treatment
system Proactiv MD you can have your
kids going back to school feeling their
best Proactiv MD includes a
prescription-strength retinoid that goes
deep into the pores to help prevent acne
safe and effective there's a three-step
system basically that will help your
teen get ready for the new school year
there's the deep cleansing face wash the
daily oil control with SPF 30 and then
the add a pauline gel which i hope i'm
not a doctor so i hope i'm pronouncing
that correctly right now for our
listeners we have a back-to-school offer
from Proactiv that you can't get
anywhere else with your Proactiv MD
order you will receive for free Proactiv
on-the-go bag which features their
t-zone oil absorber body acne wipes and
green green tea moisturizer which is
close to a $100 value but you're getting
all that 4d for free plus on top of that
so you get the free stuff I just
mentioned plus you're getting free
shipping plus a 60 day money back
guarantee okay you're getting all that
stuff but you have to go to Proactiv
dot-com slash Walsh to get this special
offer again go to proactive comm slash
Walsh to order and make your kids first
day back at school the best it could
possibly be alright let's let's move on
to this Ilhan omar thing reading now the
report and daily wire it says
representative Ilhan omar was accused of
having an affair with a married man whom
she allegedly funneled large sums of
money to through her campaign in divorce
documents filed this week the New York
Post reported dr. Beth Jordan Minette
says her cheating spouse Tim Manette
told her in April that he was having an
affair with the somali born US
representative that he even even made a
shocking declaration of love for the
Minnesota congresswoman
before he ditched her alleged filings
submitted in DC Superior Court on
Tuesday
court documents reviewed by the posts of
the Tim and Manette 38 in Jordan minute
55 separated and then it was revealed
that they were in this relationship so
on and so forth the post added the 37
year old congresswoman and mom of three
paid Tim and Manette and his east street
group approximately two hundred and
thirty thousand dollars through her
campaign since 2018 for fund raising
consulting digital communications
internet advertising and travel expenses
investigative reporters Jordan satchel
and Luke rosy AK both weighed in on the
financial disclosures that are made in
the report and okay they gave their
perspective so okay that's we don't need
to get into I'm not gonna read all the
other nitty-gritty details but you get
the idea so of course we we reiterate
the stipulations that this is all
alleged and so forth but these are
claims that are made in court filings
this is not just something that popped
up in a gossip rag that you get you know
in the in the checkout line at the
supermarket mazes and this isn't a court
filing so there's real credibility here
whether or not it's true remains to be
seen but there's credibility to these
allegations the payments that were made
the alleged payments alleged payments
funneled to her alleged lovers firm
that's a big deal and that would appear
to be the newsworthy item in all this
although you know by the kind of
conventional wisdom that's the
newsworthy part that there's money being
that there's you know abuses of campaign
funds and so on that's that at least
that's the standard view these days that
this kind of stuff is only relevant to
the public when it involves actual
crimes which this would be a crime if
it's if it's true that she misused
campaign funds and was you know giving
money to her lover or whatever but I you
know I I tend to disagree with the
standard view in my opinion the misuse
of money if that actually happened
that's a big deal that's you know
potentially a crime as I said that
that's something that should be looked
in
that to me is that is the less serious
thing okay it's more serious legally
yeah but as a voter as a person I find
the underlying issue the affair to be
the more serious manner now I was never
gonna vote for Omar in the first place
oh it's not it's not like I'm gonna say
and I don't live in Minnesota anyway so
I'm not saying that she lost my vote
because this she never had it to begin
with but this to me is still a big issue
and a relevant issue you know people say
oh this is none of our business is just
you know the personal relationships and
it's got nothing to do with us and then
of our sentence and that's not relevant
doesn't matter now I agree that it's
none of our business but now that we
know now that it's been reported now
that it's been alleged anyway you can't
help but draw all tentative conclusions
I think having an affair betraying your
own spouse destroying another marriage
breaking two vowels simultaneously all
of that to get your kicks sexually I
think that says a lot about you as a
person you know I think that reveals
something significant about you this
idea that it says nothing to us as
voters and we shouldn't pay attention to
it what I mean you're telling me that
this is not a reflection of a person's
character what it says first and
foremost is that you can't be trusted
and that's why I never understand the
people who say this the sexual affairs
of politicians shouldn't matter to us
how so don't we elect politicians on the
basis of the promises they make to us I
mean aren't you electing them because
they've said they're gonna do certain
things and you want them to do those
things and so you elect them for it I
mean you're either electing them for
that or just based on the letter next to
their name or because you like their
personality if it's either of those two
options then you're a [ __ ] frankly if
you're you know a rational person then
you're electing them because they've
said they're gonna do things and you
want them to do those things they said
they're gonna do now if you're also a
rational person you know that you know
there's a there's a not small chance
that they won't really do those things
because politicians lie so it's very
relevant you know we need to they make
the promises now we need
to assess what's the likelihood that
they're actually gonna follow through on
those things is they're gonna keep their
promises you could never get to a
hundred percent certainty but I think
there are certain things and that's
where the character comes in now you're
assessing their character and you can't
do it perfectly you don't know
everything about them you can't look
inside their head but you just look at
their character and you think okay is it
does it seem likely that this is the
kind of person whose word is their bond
and we can trust them or is it does it
seem more likely that they're a liar and
a cheat and a fraud you know that that's
a that's the calculation we have to make
and I think if a person is out having
affairs then that would seem to indicate
that they are a liar a cheat and a fraud
which would seem to indicate that we
can't trust them you know if we elect
them based on promises it does matter
whether they keep their promises right
and doesn't a person's willingness to
betray the most important promise they
ever made have a bearing on whether they
might keep less important promises the
promises that a politician makes to you
as a voter as a faceless voter in the
crowd though they don't even know you
don't know who you are they make a
promise about they're gonna they support
this policy they're gonna do this in
that thing those are important promises
and you know but they're not as
important as a marriage vow and you are
not important to them at all they don't
even know you
but when you get married your spouse is
the most important person in your life
the promise you make to them is the most
important promise you you will ever make
to anyone ever if you're willing to
break that promise then why would I have
any confidence that you're gonna keep
the less important promises that you
make to faceless people you don't even
know I mean if you're willing to think
about what enough what in a fair does to
the other to the jilted spouse to the to
the to the person being betrayed I mean
think about what a people people kill
themselves over stuff like this this is
the people this is just Devon's this is
the kind of thing that ruins a person's
life you know you get married to someone
you think
you trust them they go off and cheat on
you you don't get over that the next day
that's the kind of thing that will take
you decades to if you ever get over it
is it is this is like it's just you are
and if you're willing to do that to your
spouse to just utterly ruin them to
destroy them and while you're doing that
you you know you come home every night
and you look them in the eyes while you
know what you're doing to them and you
also know because you can't claim you
don't eventually they're gonna find out
because people always find out and when
they do it will ruin them and you know
that and you're doing it anyway so if
you're willing to do that to this person
who you know intimately and you claim to
love and whose eyes you have gazed into
why would I ever believe that you would
be unwilling to betray a promise to me
I'm nobody you don't even know me I mean
when you lie to me you just look at a
camera and do it that's easy to do so
this whole thing that it doesn't matter
what do you mean it's not of course it
matters what's obviously matters there's
a general principle here that Liars lie
cheaters cheat okay that's it now you
know everyone's told lies and they're
alive in their life everyone's probably
cheated on things hopefully you haven't
cheated on your marriage but maybe
you've cheated in an in a you know board
game it's a weave or not a test you know
when you were a kid I can't claim to be
innocent in that regard but there are
people who are just liars you know and a
liar someone just lies all the time
just constantly constantly lies it
almost like it's their default setting
if you're having an affair then you're
gonna be a liar just that's what you
want you have to be because of all the
lies you have to tell to keep that going
and so Liars lie to your cheat if I know
that someone's a liar and a cheater then
that means that they're gonna lie and
cheat which means why the hell would I
vote for them I like why would I on what
basis could I ever come to the
conclusion that I could trust them I
mean it's it's it's like if you you know
it
if you find out that your financial
manager has in the past been to jail for
you know swindling people with Ponzi
schemes are you gonna trust them with
your money that they've shown you that
they're willing to take people's money
and defraud them in these elaborate
schemes they've shown you that why would
you of all people why would you trust
them with your money at least take
someone who maybe there's a chance they
won't do that because as far as you know
they haven't done it before but if
they've if they've shown you that they
that this is what they do you're a total
you deserve to lose your money if you
invest in them and what I say is if
you're a voter voting for people who
have shown themselves to be liars and
cheats then you deserve to be betrayed
as a voter you deserve it I mean you are
literally asking for it I am
victim-blaming right now when it comes
to that but if we take this view if we
take this approach then of course we
have to apply it equally across the
board regardless of party I you know III
acknowledge that if we say that the
affairs of politicians do tell us
something relevant about them then we
can't suddenly put that insight to the
side when our favorite politician has an
affair you know what I'm saying here
about affairs and their relevance it's
either true or it isn't and if it's true
then it's true and I think it's true and
I do apply it equally if someone has an
affair in my view it means they can't be
trusted it means they're a liar and a
cheat now could there be a scenario
where you where it could be rational and
justified to vote for someone even
knowing that they're a liar and a cheat
and knowing that they're lying you lying
to you and will probably cheat you in
some respect maybe depending on the
server but but you you can't pretend
that this is that you know in this white
wall in this case over here yeah this
person did that but they're really a
great person but over here know that
person so tell Scott you can't do that
you just can't so it's but this is what
everyone does you know if if the affair
is happening this is a classic thing
Impala if the affair is happening
with someone in the opposite party then
you'll agree with everything I'm saying
right now because because it is
obviously true but then if it's your
party you say well you know what maybe
it's actually just their business and we
should stay out of it
can't do that all right so moving on
this is actually the very first thing I
saw when I came back to Twitter which
just made me even more sad that I had to
come back and can I just say as a side
note in my experience with social media
there's I'm not gonna call it an
addiction because I think addiction is
and as I've talked about before it is an
overused term and but it is a compulsion
is definitely a compulsion and I have it
and when I'm going through my day-to-day
routine and I'm live just living my life
normally I definitely have the
compulsion you know to pick up the phone
and check Twitter check social media
it's like every 5 and 1/2 seconds it's
just it's a real I just I didn't even
notice myself doing it it's like a
reflex right and I know I'm not alone in
that but the weird thing is that and
this is what makes it not an addiction
in my mind one of the things is that
when I when I step away from when I go
on vacation yeah I put the phone down
I'm not even I'm not even tempted to
look at it you know I go a week I don't
look at Twitter I don't miss it I don't
have any urge to look at it in fact I'm
I'm disgusted by the thought of it and
the first time I picked it up again
after getting back I'm I'm just bored by
it it just seems so stupid and frivolous
and irrelevant and everything everyone's
talking about just so dumb and boring
and everyone's just saying the same
things over and over again anything why
were we even doing this it's such a
waste that you know I just spent the
last week I was out you know if I had
free time I went out on the on a leg I
went fishing why don't I do that instead
why am i doing this is so it's this
weird compulsion that when you're in it
it's it's very strong and it compels you
but if it's it fades so quickly
if you just put the phone down for like
a day the compulsion is gone you have no
desire to pick it up anymore
most addictions and this why I say it's
not most addictions are not like that
with an addiction it's really hard to
step away from it and when you do
there's withdraw and you're really
hankering for it and then it's really
easy to pick it back up again but with
this with social media because it's my
job I literally have to do it as a job
so it for me to get back into Twitter
and everything was really it was like a
chore I really didn't want to do it but
once you get over that hurdle now you're
back in it and it's a compulsion again
so anyway
what was I talking about oh yeah so I
came back to Twitter and I see Kamala
Harris tweeting about a performance at
the VMAs on Sunday some other candidates
were tweeting about it - I think
Gillibrand probably tweeted about it I
don't know that but I assume but because
of her penchant for pandering I assume
she jumped on this one and the
performance was by a woman named Liz Oh
Camille Harris says that it's colorful
vibrant joyful unapologetic powerful how
could you not love Liz oh well how could
you not love it let's take a look at
this performance to find out how we
might manage to not love it let's try to
answer Camille Harris's question here's
the some of the performance from Liz oh
yes that was a giant jiggling but on the
stage in the I'm talking about the in
the background like what the one in the
in the background and those dancers were
wearing assless chaps
and it looked now I say this I'm I know
with that kind of stuff it's like
they're trying to shot oh it's it's so
shocking and edgy
now I'm not shocked by it I don't find
it edgy I find it incredibly boring oh
look it's a bunch of butts I mean that
really that's the best you get you want
to shock me that's the best you can do
and you got to work a lot harder than
that these days to shock people no
that's just boring so come on then this
is what I mean you're at the VMAs and
you're flashing but so I mean that's
like how many how many you don't mean
butts up in flashes the VMAs that's
that's to all things all day
it's this the but flashing awards
basically I mean you want to be edgy
yeah that's that's not how to do it but
it but it is it is it's not shocking
Reggie I want to make that clear but it
is it's boring and it's very very stupid
it is certainly very very stupid it's
like something out of the movie
idiocracy in fact it would be too
on-the-nose for ad accuracy if they had
shown a vision of the VMAs in 500 years
in the future which I wish they had done
actually in the movie idiocracy and they
had shown that exact performance with a
bunch of dancers and assless chaps
dancing in front of a giant jiggling but
I I would have probably not even laughed
because I would have said okay that's a
little too I mean we get it it's a movie
called idiocracy that's a little too
idiotic let's mean come on now come on
but too stupid for a movie called
idiocracy but it is not too stupid for
reality and that is what just happened
I'm you know I'm watching I'm just
trying to find and then I saw I tweeted
about this as a speaking of Twitter
getting back into Twitter this is the
first thing that I I come back to it
it's the first thing a week and a half
away the very first thing I'm talking
about is a giant jiggling but which i
think is very appropriate actually for
Twitter so in and you know I said
whatever this is stupid and there were a
lot of people sang knows this Liz o is
great and it's powerful and where is the
powerful part of this incoherent
ridiculous mind-numbing idiocy
unapologetic maybe any [ __ ] can be
unapologetic there's nothing impressive
about that but what's powerful about
this here look let's review some of the
lyrics just to just to you know because
I'm look Camille Harris and and others
say this is a powerful compelling
beautiful song and so I'm I'm just I'm
looking for it you now you tell me if
you if you if you notice the powerful
beautiful stuff just jump in and let me
know even though I won't be able to hear
you I just took a DNA test turns out I'm
a hundred percent that'd be even when
I'm crying crazy yeah I got boy problems
that's the human in me
bling-bling then I saw them that's the
goddess in me you could have had a bad
be nan
it'll help you with your career just a
little you're posed to hold me down but
you're holding me back
and that's the sound of me not calling
you back why men great till they got to
be great what why men great till they
got to be great that that just doesn't
mean anything I'm sorry that really just
means nothing those are just words that
is just dumping words onto a bit like
what you have words in a bucket and you
just dump them onto a page that's what
that is that those are not why men great
till they gotta be good
Mike two-year-old could put together a
more coherent sentence than that don't
text me tell straight to my face best
friend sat me down in the salon chair
shampoo press gets you out of my hair
fresh photos with the bomb lighting new
man on the Minnesota Vikings blah blah
blah I mean I'm looking I'm gonna hit
you back in a minute
I don't play tag I've been it we don't f
with lies we don't do goodbyes we just
keep it pushing like III I'm gonna hit
you back in a minute you know I I don't
I don't see the powerful what part of
that is powerful I don't I just don't
see it maybe it's me okay it could be
that I'm the problem I just maybe I
don't maybe this is so brilliant this is
so smart that I'm too dumb to get it
yeah that's possible
I am a pretty stupid person I admit that
so it's you know it's one way or another
either I am NOT stupid enough for this
or I'm Way too stupid for it I don't
know which it is I suspect it's probably
the the former I feel the same way about
this as I do about the I'm speaking
about our drive the the the when we were
on the drive just to make matters worse
my wife at one point put on a Taylor
Swift song and it's the one that you'll
never find a lover like me that song a
song with actual lyrics that say this is
actual lyrics in the song this is the
song says I think this is part of the
chorus says you can't spell awesome
without me I mean literally lyrics that
would be
- vapid corny self-absorbed and stupid
for a fourth grader okay if I had a
fourth grader who wrote a song for the
talent show and it included the lyrics
you can't spell awesome without me
I would ground them and forbid them from
going to the talent show I would say how
dare you this is so stupid I am
I am ashamed the you are my child I
would disown them for lyrics I would
literally and it's the same with this
okay it's it's not saying anything
there's no point to it I'm not saying
that every song has to be so brilliant
and has to have some overarching
brilliant mind-blowing point but if the
only point of the song is just look at
me I'm great but then it doesn't even
explain why okay here's my problem if
you're gonna actually write a song about
how great you are which is a really
gross and pitiful subject for a song of
all the things to talk about of all the
subjects to sing about in the world I
mean for you to choose that just shows
that there is nothing going on upstairs
you are such a shallow person you you
you just you you have never looked
outside of your all your eyeballs are
basically turned around in your head and
staring back into your own the cavity
where your brain is supposed to be you
have never if you would just look
outside of yourself and look at the
world for five seconds you would find
five hundred subjects for up for up for
a song but the only thing you think to
think about it think this thing about is
yourself and how great you are but if
you're gonna do that at least explain
why I mean talk abut give us real
reasons for maybe you are great lizzo
says she's a goddess okay maybe she is
you know seeing her dancing in front of
the jiggling but that to me that doesn't
quite communicate it but it doesn't mean
she's not a goddess I can't that's
that's a claim that you have made you're
saying I'm a goddess okay give me
evidence tell me some great things
you've done do you return your shopping
carts okay do you have you ever do do
you try to give exact change when you're
when you're you know checking out at CVS
I mean are these things that you do
but we get nothing like we had no
evidence it just all we get is just the
repeated assertion I'm great I'm great
I'm so great I'm so wonderful I mean she
says we just keep it pushing like III is
that reason she's so great I don't know
what that means may is you know if you
if a person who keeps it pushing like
III is does that mean that they're great
is that a is that a virtuous achievement
I don't even know what it is can anyone
explain that to me what does it mean to
keep it pushing like I I mean if someone
said that to you if I went up to someone
and said what you know what are you been
up to today I just keep it up pushing
like I yeah you know this one what would
that be I mean what does that mean there
anyway this is just this is just
battling and this is every song these
days I hate to say I hate to be this guy
I hate to sound like this but it and
it's every song I'm it's hyperbolic
there are some there are there are
legitimately great artists out there but
this seems like every pop song anywhere
all the popular songs most of them it's
just I'm great I'm so amazing I'm so
awesome I'm just the best look at me I'm
just so amazingly wonderful yet there is
no evidence ever presented we are never
given any reason to believe that any of
these people or even half as wonderful
as they claim and the very fact that
they're claiming it in the first place
is already compelling evidence that they
are the opposite of great and awesome
it's actually evidence that they are
losers desperate for attention and
affirmation so this whole thing and this
is what gets me to about Liz oh and you
know we're told how she's she's a she's
so confident she's all about self
confidence this isn't what confident
people do if you're really confident you
don't get up on a stage take your
clothes off shake around and say I'm so
great look at me that's not what
confident people do okay that's what
psychotics do and that's what losers who
are utterly desperate for affirmation do
those are the two peak kinds of people
who do that there are no other kinds of
people who do it a confident person you
know what a confident person does they
keep their clothes on they live their
life with quiet dignity and Asia
they're confident in themselves they
know who they are they know they're
doing what they're supposed to be doing
they know that they have flaws that
they're not perfect they would never
call themselves a god or a goddess for
God's sake but that but they they
generally you know they they're on the
right path we know and so they just walk
that path and they don't call attention
to it and if they were ever gonna write
a song because they have musical ability
it would be a song about you know the
ocean or about about you know anything
about love about about about humpback
whales I mean really any any subject
they would write a song on any subject
aside from how great they are they
wouldn't even occur to them to write a
subject a song about that because they
don't spend time thinking about
themselves in their own greatness so
that's all to say that I think that's a
really bad song just summarize and I
think we'll leave it there I was gonna
do some emails today but I have so many
emails which I appreciate by the way I
do appreciate but I've got a sort throw
them and that might take me a couple of
days but we'll get back to answering
listener emails too as well soon enough
I don't know why I'm holding my hands
like this at the end of the show just
ending with a prayer I suppose but we'll
leave it there and I'll talk to you guys
tomorrow Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by
Robert Sterling associate producer
alexia Garcia Del Rio executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Donovan Fowler
audio is mixed by Mike Cora Mena the
Matt Walsh show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 19 if
you prefer facts over feelings if you
aren't offended by the brutal truth if
you can still laugh at the nuttiness
filling our national news cycle well
tune on into the Ben Shapiro show or
you'll get a whole lot of that and much
more we'll see you there
you